depuis quelques jours les parisiens
peuvent prouver dans certaines
boulangeries de la capitale un nouveau
pain alors notre curiosité nous ayant
poussé à en savoir davantage nous sommes
entrés dans une boulangerie du xviie
arrondissement avoir une baguette
oui super super justement jouer parce
que c'est que ce pain super oui je le
permettez je vous avais attendait est
avant tout la chêneraie ne vous
inquiétez pas mais ce que je peux la
limité parce que je ne la connais assez
bien
certainement je peux mais attendez je
vais rompre le pain voyez en avril amis
et plus est jolie elle est légère
l'appel est lancé avec d'autres copains
et bien écoutez il est fabriqué à base
d'une part une supérieure vers une fête
avec le t2 les sélectionnés qui ont
frotté ou plus élevé que les blés
courant oui et disons plutôt retenons un
travail est meilleur il ya bien sûr une
certaine façon de perdre mais on peut
obtenir une qualité nettement supérieure
d'ailleurs vous devez dia que même une
différence même visuel entre les deux os
il est très bon a dit moyenne plus chers
n'ont rien il coûte plus cher écoute
légèrement plus cher mémorial est
également intéressée elle pas les
pauvres non non pas plus qu il y a le
vad est riche et le vin des pauvres
quand on achète une bouteille de vin
ordinaire on le choisit quelques points
africains selon ap légèrement supérieur
que je ne pense pas que la différence
porte à conséquence
j'essayais madame avait bien sûr
pourquoi pas oui ya par exemple si vous
pensez que vous trouverez quelques
frayeurs qu'il allait spécial vous allez
le voir venir goûter non mais pour
délivrer à l'avenir ancienne ville et je
voulais tout savoir willy loin de paris
de france ce soir la télévision et canal
auraient tous et vous montrez votre faim
en même temps un petit problème sans me
sentais déjà mangé